Jeff Howell covers the Patriots they're
beat writer with Boston Herald with the
ESPN expose that we've been talking
about came out last night at 10 o'clock
the Patriots media availability not
until next week so there's a whole lot
to talk about and the Patriots don't
play this weekend so Jeff joins us now
Jeff what do you make of this story I
mean this is a storyline that is sort of
hung overhead during the course of the
season and I think and I don't want to
take any shots at the author or the
story itself but I think really it's a
oh it's tough to draw the parallel
between an argument between Brady and
Belichick that stemmed from them not
seeing eye-to-eye over Alex Guerrero's
involvement with the team this season
and then insinuating that will
essentially lead to the demise of the
dynasty and ultimately their working
relationship Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick basically for the the long
majority of their 18 seasons together
have always had a standard player coach
relationship a quarterback coach
relationship they're not best friends
they don't hang out off you know away
from the facility or anything like that
but that doesn't mean they're enemies
and I think with a lack of I don't know
a lack of other drama surrounding the
team this season that is you know don't
look deflategate in the past years and
stuff like that Brady's suspension last
season I think it's been overblown to an
extent that again something between
Brady Guerrero and Belichick is all of a
sudden caused this divide that will be
irreparable and I just don't think that
that's the case they've argued in the
past I mean there are they've argued
over at this season and it's nothing
really more than that this is it's
they'd be weird if those two guys didn't
have arguments I'll put it that way what
role do you think Brady played in Jimmy
Garoppolo being and being traded
absolutely well I mean directly
absolutely none Brady I can promise you
Brady had no demands whatsoever to get
Jimmy Garoppolo sent out of town but if
you want to say
indirectly I mean it was it was the
entire story you go into this season
with the Patriots having Garoppolo
knowing he was only under contract for
one more year
just as an insurance policy they got the
trade calls last these last offseason
most notably from the Browns who were
the most aggressive out of every team
that calls the the talks were basically
it got to the point where Bella Tech
would have had to one it had to win a
Garofalo trade to a laughable extent for
him to accept anything because he wanted
to bring her up low back mostly for
insurance for Brady one he wanted to
make sure the Brady wasn't gonna look
like a 40 year old quarterback - he
understood how good this roster was and
it's not like Brady had to suffer
another ACL injury or anything like that
he wanted to make sure that if Brady
went down for let's say four to four
games at any point during the 2017
season that they weren't all of a sudden
going to go off the rails and lose the
chance they traded Garoppolo they
weren't sold the perset was going to be
the guy at the time they didn't want to
all decide go oh and four and miss their
chance and you know not make the
playoffs or have a team that could get a
first-round bye and then following fall
into a wild-card round and have to win
that extra clocking so that's why they
kept Garoppolo around for as long as
possible then over the summer in
training camp Brady looked remarkable he
was lights out yet again he looked just
like Tom Brady always has every summer
and that started to open some eyes and
there were you know they were a little
wary of Garoppolo and his injury history
remember he got injured last year second
start he wasn't able to play the next
two peaks they tried to put a little
pressure on him to see if he would come
back from that sprained shoulder he
couldn't I Garoppolo also missed a
practice or a portion of the offseason
workout program with a calf injury so
they were kind of skeptical over his
durability
so then Brady goes out and has that
great summer and it was an eye-opener it
was okay you know Brady's the guy and it
looks like he's going to be the guy for
the foreseeable future like he always
has been and now you got to figure out
what are you gonna do with Garoppolo
and I think Belichick always hoped vicar
oppelo would take a deal to become
Brady's
main as Brady's backup Garoppolo just
never had any designs to do that he
wanted to start after this season so
they had to franchise somewhere they had
to trade him and the rubber met the road
I'm also curious about this that it's an
ESPN story and who would the pay who in
the Patriots organization or even Bill
Belichick friends like why cooperate
with ESPN for this story and maybe I'm
conspiracy theorists here but you know
there's not a good relationship between
the mothership and the Patriots why
would somebody be you know dishing to
ESPN yeah I mean that's a great question
and and I would hate to I'm not gonna
question somebody else's sources but I
think if you just look at the way Bill
Belichick operates the the greatest
creep that he has in my opinion is he's
always been a master at avoiding
distractions whether it was spy gate or
deflate gate or I mean whatever those
are the three biggest ones but I mean
you go back to preparing for the Super
Bowl in 2004 and the way that he was
able to get that team to go 14 and 2 and
back-to-back sees motivating them in
different ways same types of of
adversity I guess if you want to call it
that this season is they're trying to
win three or four again I mean there's
trying to keep this team motivated so
with how much work that Bill Belichick
has put in to making sure that this team
could go thirteen and three despite a
number of different obstacles almost all
of them on the football field is is it's
been a remarkable it's been remarkable
behind the scenes what he's been able to
do so all of a sudden on the eve of the
playoff just sort of drop a cherry bomb
in a in a trash can and then just walk
away and risk blowing up his locker room
or anything like that I mean I just it
none of that makes sense it would be
completely out of character Brady of
course would never do that so who are
who are these other people who were out
here talking for this stuff I mean I
don't know I don't want a question who
they could be or insinuate who I think
they could be but I'm just saying what
the main parties involved that would be
completely uncharacteristic
based off of two decades of work if I
gave you a chance to have one question
either Brady or Belichick next week and
you know that they would give you an
honest answer who do you ask the
question - and what's that question how
long is Bill Belichick gonna coach the
Patriots I mean look Brady I'm convinced
Brady said it so many times that he's
gonna play until he's 45 or 46 I have no
idea what Phyllis Bellatrix contract
status is I have no idea how long he
wants to stay around I've tried so many
different ways to try to figure this out
if I could find that one out that that'd
be the golden goose right there how
would you word the question because
that's always interesting when you're
talking to Belichick I'll be Belichick
and and Jeff you'll you you uh you ask
the question
so wait you're gonna give me the truth
no matter what yes
no I mean I'll do I'll give them this
favorite type of question I'll ask it
pointedly how long are you coaching the
Patriots no well I um this next couple
of week and guaranteed
I'm not going to coach show this weekend
after that I'm gonna I'm I that's all
you get that's all I got that's like I
can't even get there sorry I got my
answer my sorry Jeff I can't get there
you know I'm just going I'm gonna coach
the next game that's it
so I'm gonna do how do you think how did
I do with my Belichick I'll work on my
Brady for you as well
hey have fun you should be great next
week to go to those press conferences
and thank you Jeff that's Jeff how
Patriots beat writer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]